[Music]
the power of the enemy is growing
war on this country will come swiftly
for Sauron will have dominion over all
life on this Earth who now has the
strength to stand against Asian guard
and Lord
and the union of the two towers
the strength of the ring bearer is
failing
and the creature Golem
senses the ring is close
[Music]
foreign
I come back to you now at the turn of
the tide
praise
brothers or sisters
who can
Brigade on me and my queen with some
myth thank you
[Music]
oh greatest of Kings
let one of your nights try to let them
glow against me indulge me in this game
[Music]
one
year hence
[Music]
another year nearly gone already
you seek him out was it not just a game
perhaps
but it is not complete
oh
hello
do I said hand
s
we rest your bones I'll finish your
quest for you
facing all of this
honor
that is why night does what he does
[Music]
are you ready
here's the thing we're a team of Thieves
then when you do this
you're bound to make enemies
sometimes those enemies come looking for
Revenge
truth be told
we helped the wrong person steal the
wrong thing
it didn't mean to unleash the greatest
evil the world has ever known
but we're gonna fix it so how do we pull
that off
uh figure it out over a drink probably
best you need food
it's a fighting chance we're gonna need
strength you got this right I know you
don't
we also need courage
magic
and you
what is that again it's now there
[Music]
there is evil here
I'm glad he's on our side
this one's dangerous
but whatever happens
we'll be ready
is it exactly that you bring to this I'm
a planner I make plans you've already
made the plant so the existing plan
fails I make a new plan so you make
plans that fail no he also plays the
loot not relevant
[Music]
hurry be safe
be strong
Harry Potter
[Music]
you have fought valid
now join me and confront your fate
you've kept him alive so they can die at
the proper moment bring it to me
find out where he is
protect us
it's a suicide mission
the boy who lived
come to die
how you looked him in the eye a man who
trusted you and killed
any of you to die for me
you'll stay with me until the end
let's finish this the way we started I
forget about it
only I can live forever
[Music]
if I told you about her
the princess without voice
what would I say
[Music]
Eliza come on
foreign
[Music]
you clean that lab you get out
this may very well be the most sensitive
asset ever to be housed in this facility
you may think that thing looks human
stands on two legs right but we're
created in the Lord's image you don't
think that's what the Lord looks like
man this creature is intelligent capable
of language
of understanding emotions
[Music]
when he looks at me he doesn't know how
I am incomplete he sees me as I am
yeah
[Music]
the natives in the Amazon where's it
like a god
get him out what are you talking about
we need to take it apart learn how it
works
I don't want an intricate beautiful
thing destroyed
you can do nothing I'm sorry don't do
this Eliza what is she saying don't do
this
it's not even human
if I told you about her
what would I say I wonder
[Music]
in a dark time when hope was bleak
if the young girl
whose only Escape
was in a legend that wanted her back
the legend speaks of the lost soul of a
princess from another world
who will one day be reborn
there will be signs
that Mark her return
[Music]
there will be secrets
that reveal her Destiny
there will be a journey
that will make you believe
[Music]
thank you
from picture house
and the imagination of Guillermo del
Toro
[Music]
Darkness
there can be light
in misery there can be Beauty
there can be life
[Music]
Pan's Labyrinth
okay you ready
there we go
what color is that
maybe if we take a pencil
let me make a face
[Music]
and we see the life in the eyes
there's a monster
how does the story begin
how coming to live with me don't touch
anything
too young
to be a man I no longer see
what did he do
[Music]
he called
from Monsters
[Music]
I know everything about you the truth
that you hide the truth you dream
I'm sorry you have to face this but you
have to be brave do you understand
[Music]
break them yourself it's okay that
you're angry I'm angry too and if you
need to break things
[Music]
I wish I had a hundred years
a hundred years I could give to you
I'm afraid of course you are afraid but
you will make
for this is why you called me come on
there is a place like no place on Earth
some say to survive it you need to be as
mad as a Hatter which luckily
I am Alice it's you
you're back Alice Alice
you're absolutely Alice I know you
anywhere
Wonderland
the Red Queen has taken over all of
[Music]
I love a warm Pig belly for my aching
feet that's not bad foreign
[Music]
thank you
impossible
[Music]
take them there is a prophecy the two
sons of Adam and two doors of Eve will
appear to defeat the White Witch
empty this hundred year of winter I
think you've made a mistake we're not
Heroes there's no mistake Aslam is on
the move
Hassan we need your help I know
I never understand the future of Narnia
rests on your courage if it's a war
Iceland wants
The Voice you'll get
they're counting numbers far greater
than our own numbers do not win a battle
no but I bet they help
there is a world where witches rule the
northern Skies where Ice Bears are the
bravest of Warriors and where every
human is joined with an animal spirit
who is as close to them as their own
heart are we going to see the child
I should think so but this world is
dominated by the magisterium
seeks to control all humanity and whose
greatest threat is a Golden Compass and
the one child
destined to possess it
what's this it's The Golden Compass I
feel you're meant to have it but what's
it for it lets you Glimpse what is to
come to the utmost importance for all
creation
I don't know I have to go back to the
north very soon perhaps you should come
along me go to the north north
it's cold up there
are you familiar with the process of the
witches you think she's that child
when he was leaving the college the
master of John gave you something didn't
he
I don't want to
and it's her she's running the
magisterium
these are the Chiefs of the Egyptian
families who are under our protection
you're on I'd hire myself an armored
bear
and I will serve you
campaign
champagne have a victory
she is in possession of The Golden
Compass
she must be first
the magisterium seeks to control every
world you will need all your skill and
courage
we will strike the strength
you value your life come no further
I'll never be yours
thank you
foreign
to run with the pack one of these days
you'll be someone's dinner
[Music]
I can't help but notice there's this
strange odor today
man is forbidden
the jungle is no longer safe for you but
this is my hope only man can protect you
now
[Music]
for a sweet little Coke what are you
doing so deep in the jungle
you are a man Cub who wants to live in a
jungle how do you know that kid I got
ears my ears got ears only I can protect
you
[Music]
forget about your worries
what's that that's a song about the good
life
foreign
nothing until he has this boy if
anything happens to that kid I'll never
forgive myself
[Music]
come on Mowgli let's be on our way but
I'm happy
I'm helping Bears don't hibernate in a
jungle not full hibernation but I nap a
lot
you've known for 24 hours that an
unregistered wizard set magical Beast
loose in New York yes where is this man
[Music]
so year to go with the case full of
monsters huh Can you travels first
which is Fanta do you know anything
about the Wizarding community in America
don't let things loose
Mr English guy I think your egg is
hatching
he liked his memory right The Nomad what
no magic the non-wizard sorry we call
them Muggles
I don't think I'm Dreaming I'll give it
away I ain't got the brains to make this
up
all right
in our city
wreaking destruction
and then disappearing Without a Trace
witches live among us
ask all of you
who does this
engine
it's related to Grindelwald attacks in
Europe this could mean War
we got a plan right guys they need our
help
[Music]
I won't let another one die I refuse to
bow down any longer
time is running out it's just command
thank you
the last place Jared Grace wanted to be
I know this house isn't perfect but we
can make it work it was stuck here oh
the house yeah it's great if you like
big creepy houses in the middle of
nowhere
check it out this one has its secrets
don't you want to know where this thing
goes not really
[Music]
do not dare to read this book
Arthur spiderwicks feel good dear reader
you will soon see that there are
Fantastical creatures living among us
[Music]
why can't I see you you don't see us now
you do but only if we want you to
forewarned a rare few are quite frankly
to be feared
you took a book I put a note right on
the cover can't you read
all around us goblins troll Sprites you
gotta believe me impossible you're such
a liar keep a box safe from the ogre
ogre
[Music]
oh my God
whose side are you on your side yeah
you ready now I'm ready let's go
I think we give it to him
The Spiderwick Chronicles did I hit
somebody yes
[Music]
I was out here at the Eastern pad
but that's 50 miles east from where we
found him
hey
do you know where your parents are your
family
well I guess he was on a picnic or a
camping trip he wandered off and got
himself lost
I've been out in the woods doing things
his own way I sounded like a boy after
your own heart
how long has he been out there six years
nobody can survive in that forest for
six years
at least not alone
you'll see I have Elliot
[Music]
who's Elliot
I need to get back to him he gets scared
when I'm gone is Elliot a person no he
looks like a dragon what's a dragon
that's a dragon
you don't have to run anymore Pete you
can stay with us
this thing is dangerous you don't
believe you but he'll come looking for
you
what's gonna happen to Elliot you have
no idea what this thing was capable of
Let's Go Hunt
very brave did you know that you might
be bravest boy I've ever met
attention all units where eastbound on
millhaven Road in pursuit of a dragon
it's a dragon you can't see Dragon over
the radio
my dear Bell you're so ahead of your
time this is a small village you are the
most gorgeous thing I've ever seen
nobody deserves you and it's
small-minded as well that's small also
means safe
oh
this
listen to my father he's a thief come
into the light
girl who said that hello
you can talk I don't know of course it's
all he ever does
how lovely to mate your acquaintance
wanna see me do a trick
it's when the last paddle Falls
remains a beast forever and we become
antiques
what does he do to it nothing get out of
here
you have to help me you have to stand
thank you
if she is the one
who'll break the spell you must finally
learn to love
have you really read every one of these
books some of them are in Greek
turns
rising in the east
[Music]
where does your journey
and you seek that which would bestow
upon you the right to rule
to reclaim a Homeland
and slay a dragon
do not think I won't kill you
when did we allow evil to become
stronger than us
it is not our fight
[Music]
son got it there that's happened
such is the nature of evil
in time all thou things come forth
[Music]
you'll Destroyer
was that an earthquake that's my land
was a dragon
[Music]
of all the classic Disney stories
of all the miraculous Adventures
of all the magical tales
there's never been anything like
Enchanted
[Music]
thank you because no other story has
ever taken you
to a land of strange and terrifying
as ours
oh my I was wondering if one of you
fights directly to the castle of watches
will you
nobody's been very nice to me yeah well
welcome to New York
thank you
this is how I will rescue you no who's
gonna Rescue Me
I seek a beautiful girl I I'd like to
find one of them too you know their
world and our world I think she may be a
real princess are about to collide all
right everyone let's tidy things up
oh my gosh and nothing will ever be the
same
this Thanksgiving how does she know
don't say it's okay you know let's just
walk one ordinary man will have to get
them back home before time Runs Out
magic mirror I beg you tell me where she
is reporting from 116th and Broadway
116th and Broadway
[Music]
of Disney Pictures
event of the holidays
[Music]
are you crazy nobody stabs my bus don't
you run away from me crazy tightwear
Enchanted Giselle
[Music]
thank you